uh are you ready to strike out for a
good cause special olympics nevada has
its bowl for the gold event a little
more than a week away but you can still
get involved bianca holman is live with
us this morning with more details bianca
good morning
hey good morning john no gutter balls
over here my girl christine she has been
kicking him down all morning long you
saw her but so this is a great event
bowl for the gold so tell us more elise
about
this event and how it's coming up pretty
soon so yeah this is one of the most
popular events here in las vegas it's
super fun event you register a team you
get to bowl
three games you get shoes you get pizza
you get to have a really super fun time
with us and all my athletes
this year we have truman orthodontist
and henderson coming out as a sponsor as
well as the las vegas raiders as a
sponsor so we're really excited to have
them on board and we're really really
looking forward to having the community
come out and really support the special
olympics here in nevada yeah and that's
what the money goes towards all the
money that's raised and donated helps
and stays right here in our valley
absolutely every
bit of this fundraiser goes directly to
support the programs here in nevada it
all stays in state all right so we got
to talk to one of our top athletes
christine i know you've been in special
olympics for a few years now you know
you're a pro so what do you love most
about uh participating in special
olympics i love um
i love people love meeting new people
meeting new friends and getting to
interact with other people yeah and then
also the bowl for the gold event coming
up you've been there before what do you
love most about uh you know doing that
fundraiser and bowling for a call great
cause
to um to help to let people come out and
support us yeah there's a great turnout
so again there's still space for you to
come out and support athletes like
christine so go ahead let's show off
those skills because i know bowling is
one of your
wow looking good looking good look
anthony down there cheering her on so
again this is a great cause you guys and
of course we'll be tweeting out this
information it'll be on our social media
and also on our website so all great
things happening and you know what i got
some competition here
i did pretty good a little bit earlier
we were all playing out here here in the
park so we're going to send it back to
you guys there in the studio i think
christine was showing you up a little
bit there beyond guy he had some pretty
pretty impressive skills we should point
out this is at sunset station it'll be
saturday august 28th so next week uh go
help out the special olympics and bianca
we'll catch up with you a little bit
later on this morning